what's that believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have the ability to create something
special that will change the planet so
to help you on your journey I started to
mentor me series and the goal here is to
try to hang around people who've done a
lot more than us who achieved massive
success and hopefully by hanging around
them a little bit longer some of their
mindsets their attitudes their beliefs
the way they see the world will seep in
to us to help us become the best version
of ourselves so today we're going to
learn from Bishop TD jakes
and how to soar mentor me Bishop Jake's
[Music]
you
soare when I sat down to write it was
written solely and exclusively to people
who had inspirations for being
entrepreneurial because I grew up in a
home with entrepreneurship and I'm very
passionate about it and I've expressed
it to my children as I began to write it
I thought this is also true for people
who are starting churches the same land
set was applicable because a non true a
person who goes to work goes to work to
perform a task and when the task is over
they go home an entrepreneur doesn't
have hours an entrepreneur takes full
responsibility for everything you can't
be one-dimensional and be an
entrepreneur just because you like to
bake cookies doesn't mean that you can
just think about baking cookies you've
got to think about packaging you got to
think about marketing you got to think
about health inspections you got to
think about stamp developing you have to
think about everything of the buck stops
with you so you have to be a global
thinker to be an entrepreneur we are
taught we are teaching people to be
specialists in one dimension and it was
very much like pastoring a church
starting a church you started a church
you can't just worry about one of the
caprices Sunday there are preachers who
who come to work for churches who are so
organized that they are hired to preach
but if you started church
you better be hard to clean bathrooms
you better be hard to drive the bus you
better be hard to balance the books you
have to be hard to do a whole lot of
stuff you know I worked my way out of
doing all this stuff
I started out you know I was a choir
director the head of the Dinka board to
clean up community at the janitorial
service and the marketing director I had
to be everything that's an
entrepreneurial mindset and I continued
to write the book I realized that I
wasn't talking about a thing I was
talking about a mentality the mentality
says I take responsibility for where my
life is going well so I wrote the books
or to say to you whether you're working
a job and need when you work a job I'll
tell you what I'll pay you but what I'm
willing to pay you may not be how much
you need to make
so you might need multiple streams of
income in order to get what you are
really worth even though I've determined
what I'm going to pay you you cannot
allow my evaluation and assessment of
what you are worth to my company stream
to be the substratum of what you hope to
get for your dream and your purpose you
understand so whether it is subsidizing
your income with multiple streams of
income as I've mentioned to you while
I'm sitting here talking to you we're
filming in Pittsburgh you don't always
have to be present to be productive okay
I talk in the book about building the
team around you in building I call it
the machine building the machine is
imperative for you to be functional the
only reason I can sit here right now is
that I have a team of staff people who
are sending me takes up to the very last
minute before I walked out here telling
me what's going on in all the videos all
the time all the while what's being shot
what's being handled all that's going on
you have to build around you and
infrastructure and this is what the
reason one of the reason of the book is
I watched my father's started a business
with the mop of the bucket one lock one
bucket borrowed a truck went to clean up
a place and turn it into a business with
52 employees and 10 truck service in the
state of West Virginia doing a
janitorial service and one of the things
had stopped it from going nationwide in
my view is that he wouldn't stop mopping
you understand what I'm saying my father
was such a hustler and a good sense he
was a good hustler he was it was hard to
describe what he did because he did
everything to survive his 1960 and then
when he started working he was good at
working took pride in what he did but in
order to really get your hand on things
things you have to stop doing and start
being the John Maxwell says if you know
how to do a thing you will always have a
job but if you know why they're doing it
they will always work for you you are
only limited by how you use the same
thing
gave everybody 24 hours the differences
in income is based on what you did with
the time he gave you everybody has the
same day but everybody had to have the
same thing sword is about understanding
why is it that somebody wakes up in the
morning and they come home with ten
thousand when I come home with 150 when
we had the same 24 hours and I'm saying
it is as much a mindset as it is
anything else as a young boy I was
enthralled by airplanes and the wonder
of whether I would ever embark on a
flight that would carry me to new
exciting adventures and a life of
limitless possibilities I came to know I
had the power within me to soar and that
has made all the difference in my life
flying for the first time is a lot like
creating your own business launching a
start-up or establishing a
non-for-profit organization both require
a leap of faith and a willingness to
take a journey of unexpected variables
in other words both require a little bit
of crazy and a whole lot of courage
don't let fear hold you back from doing
what you truly love commit to your
vision and be the CEO of your future you
wouldn't be in this room if you didn't
have a vision it wouldn't be a mystery
Michigan help me worry about the vision
Lord than the provision I find that the
vision the provision comes to the vision
a lot of people ask for provision who
have no vision and and money runs from
blindness money runs from blindness yes
here money runs from blood it's money
Bishop you might need to unpack that one
okay well force them if they're if there
is no purpose there is no provision and
and and I'm not talking about physical
blindness I'm talking about blindness so
far as career and future until you
figure out the first thing the bank
wants to know is what do you want to do
buddy who's gonna invest in you wants to
see here what do you see what do you see
when jesus healed a blind man in touch
with you refer time he asked him what do
you see because his response is based on
his answer so the man said I see man
walking his trees each of them touch you
again until I clear up your vision we
can't leave this spot if you the first
time I went to the bank it was amazing
they wanted a seven-year projection of
our company and I thought wow I didn't
know anything about business I thought
what in the world do they want therefore
I could write down anything what they're
really asking you is have you thought
through the future they're asking you
can you see because if you can see we
will fund what you see pro vision but if
there is no vision how can there be
provision so we when we want something
as God for provision but you need to be
asking for vision because if you get a
clear vision and you're passionate about
it people support people not ideas so if
you're not excited about it why should I
give to it so entrepreneurship is not
about world would love gold is about
who's gonna be proud and I says why are
you letting somebody else drive your
economic future and control it by a
painting being the only way to make
money so so when we start talking about
in those terms
people's brain started and they started
thinking and they approached finance is
different and so I don't even want to
sell a book I don't want to sell out a
conference I want to start a
conversation doing conference and
through a book then brings forth fruit
in your pocketbook because it's a
beginning
your hand you can get it in your pocket
yes I want to try to move it that's it
exactly what I've talked about I want to
start a move I want to lead the world
better than I found it
I want to let America hear the things
that I heard as a child they cost me to
be entrepreneurial all of my life it's
something I'm very passionate about I
come from generations of entrepreneurs
and even though I worked a job I always
have a hustle too because I don't
believe that anybody has the right to
say what I'm worth you can say what you
will pay but you cannot say how much I
make because what you pay me may only be
one stream that feeds my Garden of Eden
and head for but you are only limited by
your own creativity if you take back
your girlfriend time you gossiping time
you're arguing with people who are gonna
change side you can turn all that in the
capital is you choose to invest in bed
places we all have the same 24 hour day
and so the book is called sold some
Eagles fly from the mountain and some
Eagles die in the bath and the
difference is what did you do with your
wings you get to choose whether you
struggle or succeed based on your own
creativity and I can't remember exactly
how to say it but but it really boils
down to this whole notion that if you
don't have a strategy you're gonna have
a struggle that's really what I'm most
often and you're a bit - you're a woman
a six year old woman 50 67 year old
person you can't count on your kids to
take care of you if you don't develop
and I can screen this from the rooftop
why don't we let a surprise us in one's
ass every day is coming and if you don't
have a strategy that accommodates
18 you're gonna have a struggle you know
you're gonna may not have a porch like
your grandma
to keep our mother so you can't count on
your kids to take care of you and won't
be on TV if you waste your strength
without a strategy and then get shot
because in racine years you have a
struggle you will eat the fruit of
neglect because you failed to plan but
this season in your life
entrepreneurship says I had a strategy
so I won't have a struggle you know when
I started writing the book I thought I
was writing by entrepreneurs but the
further I got over to the book I thought
gosh since we started at church you need
to stay once you're starting a family
you be distilling then suddenly I
realized this isn't a job skill it's a
mindset and as the book with him to
develop because it develops while you're
writing it I began to recognize that
this is about taking control of how you
want your life to be its outcome and
designing it in such a way that you are
ultimately fulfilled and so we call it
soar because it's built around the Oval
Wright brothers and their whole mission
to stand on the ground and see a bird in
there and say I belong up there building
something to get you there that's what
it's all about you if you think you
belong up there and you're down here you
have to build a machine that will take
you to your dreams
hello this is Bishop TD jakes
and I just wanted to thank heaven for
making this video and you for watching
it remember don't stop at where you are
as if it were the destination when in
fact in reality it may be the
transportation that brings you into that
thing you were created to do I also have
a new book coming out in October called
soar that you can pre-order now if you
check the description below thank you so
much thank you guys so much for watching
I hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
did you learn from this video that
you're going to immediately apply
somehow to your life for your business
it was the single most important lesson
that you learned leave it down in the
comments below I'm really curious to
find out I also want to give a quick
shout out to Marta Magdalena Marta thank
you so much for picking up a copy of my
book your one word and doing that
awesome YouTube review on it as well I
really appreciate the support and I'm so
glad you enjoyed the book your one words
and the author is even Carmichael great
book by the way so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon